Think of the most beautiful thing you can imagine.
Is it a rose, a snow-capped mountain, a rhythmic dance or a distant galaxy?
For me, I think of Glacier Bay in Alaska.
It's magnificent and it's truly beautiful.
I also think of the aqua colored water and the coral in the Caribbean.
Regardless of what came to your mind, I doubt any of you when I asked the question
thought beauty, I don't believe there's real beautiful things in the world.
the reality is we all actually believe in objective beauty and
yet interestingly when asked most people would say they agree with the statement
that beauty is in the eye of the beholder so which is it is beauty a
real part of the world in which we live or is it entirely a matter of personal
preference like choosing an ice cream flavor if
you find yourself agreeing with the statement that beauty is in the eye of the
beholder, then you need to at least realize that you are in the minority in terms of
history. That's right. Most thinkers from a variety of traditions have believed that
there are three transcendentals that stand outside of human opinion.
Goodness, truth, and beauty.
And if beauty really exists, then there's good reason to believe there's a God or
some kind of divine artist responsible for making the world beautiful you
might be thinking wait a minute how can beauty be objective a real feature of the
world when people differ over what they think is beautiful after all when it comes
to music taste some people like rap other people like country when it comes to art
some people like paintings of landscapes where other people like art that is more
abstract. How can beauty be real when there's such disagreement?
At first, this seems like a strong objection but keep a couple things in mind.
First, nothing follows logically from disagreement.
People disagree over all sorts of things but does that mean there's no truth?
Take science and history. People differ over what is historically true and over what
is scientific fact. does that mean there's no facts and there's no truth of course
not we
could spend all day arguing over which of these two flowers is most beautiful what
would come of it probably not much but we would still agree that there's such a
thing as beauty we would still agree that flowers can't possess that property and in
fact we would agree that flowers many times really are beautiful
Second, what do we do with disagreements?
Music tastes, for example. There is still general agreement that certain rhythmic
patterns, structures and arrangements are necessary for music to be beautiful.
And while people may disagree over what particular features of a person are
beautiful, there is agreement that human beings can truly be beautiful.
The universal recognition of beauty in nature – crashing waves, a sunset or a rose –
must not be missed even though we may disagree on the particulars we
certainly speak as if we think beauty is objective when we say a rose is beautiful
we speak as if we think there's some property or characteristic that that rose
itself possesses when we talk about a poem being beautiful we seem to be indicating
that we think there's a quality of the poem itself that is beautiful in other words
when we say that something is beautiful we mean that that individual thing has the
universal property of beauty so when i say to my wife you are beautiful i mean
that she has a property of beauty that's something she possesses as a person
and her beauty is just as real a feature of her as the fact that she has a certain
height and a certain eye color you might not quite be fully convinced yet but you do
have to admit that we at least speak as if we believe that beauty is real.
So here's the question, can pantheism and naturalism adequately explain beauty?
According to naturalism our ability to recognize beauty is some evolved trait that
we inherited from our ancestors.
Now first glance this might seem reasonable after all if a species of beings found
their environment pleasing they would be more likely to survive, arguably.
The problem is we don't just find the world pleasing, we find it beautiful.
We explore the depths of the ocean and we peer into the most distant galaxies and we
regularly find beauty. The world is filled with beauty but it's
seemingly gratuitous beauty that has no survival value.
What about pantheism? can it adequately explain beauty?
As you will remember on pantheism, all is one.
So there's really no distinctions in nature that are real.
So what that means is there's no genuine difference between beauty and between
ugliness. So rather than accounting for why we find beauty in nature,
Pantheism simply explains beauty away as an illusion.
The Christian worldview takes beauty seriously.
Since God himself is beautiful and he has crafted the world with purpose and order,
we should expect to find beauty in creation.
And that is exactly what we find.
The splendor of a waterfall, the magnificence of a diamond or the grandeur of a
sequoia tree. the world is filled with beauty.
Just take a look at the world around you, or even take out your smartphone and look
at the photos. Our hearts resonate when we experience beauty.
The existence of real beauty in the world may not prove that God exists, but it is
one powerful pointer that the world has been fashioned with purpose, order, and
beauty by a divine artist.